you guys ever date anyone that you met
at the club and would you yeah
absolutely not I let him take me on
dates but I never did anything sexual
with him with him and why do you say
absolutely not
I just think that if you want to have a
healthy relationship with somebody I
can't speak for everybody but I would
not be okay with my I know what goes on
in the strip club and I'm not okay with
what goes on in this trip today
a lot of a lot of the stuff with some
other dancers some dancers do extras I
don't the men too though I can't tell
you how many times I have been sitting
at a table with a guy who's just going
on and on about how much he hates his
wife or his girlfriend or whatever and
that just
that's not what I want for myself